all right welcome to another edition of
on lips Ponte this is my competitor
Mario Roper and tonight I got $94 y94
ask Richard corner okay he didn't pay up
that's the hope
so here's 94 bucks if he wins any of the
four games he will win the 94 dollars if
we draw we will just replay in the match
with same colors the USDF raided touch
move and make sure you promote you know
promote before you leave a pawn on the
background making a legal move you lose
okay you ready for this Mario let's get
it all all right good luck and talking
is a lot talking so fantastic especially
especially when you gonna give me three
pawns
sure that playoff six the answer is No
too many options
Cass
great
okay
retreat
let's go
interesting interesting
okay
it's taken it straight to me
distract that then you'll see what movie
played they will figure it out figure
all right Mario that wasn't that a good
sequence for you
extra player
oh I don't know if I'm gonna win up or I
don't know if I'm gonna win one of
things I just know I'm gonna try to do
my best and and try to get a win out of
one of those games three more yes
you ready for this very interesting
it's a trick it's a trick it's a trick
I don't know exactly what the trick is
but that's a better safe than sorry but
it is a trick
luckily Danny but you just show me that
earlier it's like probably what a
humiliate myself oh yes
Oh tactic tactic shucks
I don't get ridiculed for doing this boo
boo oh okay
how could you how could I add off
Oh scary move scary scary man
well it's not like I'm not gonna plate
chucks hey how's it go you guys
okay wanted to god that's the look if
these guys start playing here I'm yes
yeah okay okay
Mario agrees all right all right
everybody knew you play that move but I
had something drawn off in case you did
it oh yeah this guy's excited for ya
okay all right that's your weakness why
you keep train Queens when when you're
behind all right yeah if you count them
up if you count them up you don't have
enough don't have as many points as me
I'm gonna go there anyway well maybe it
might work out the old-fashioned way
okay you like that you like that
maneuver Oh what am i doing okay okay
okay I have a prediction in this match
Mario will not get back rope checkmated
and neither will I
I guess King up a thunder huh don't
think as king of the fender
hey Emily as you go downstairs into your
lesson check o backward chick made
insulin peanut oh my
all right
what does that do you'll have to tell me
what those are and I'll never do it
figure it out at least you got Chuck and
most Coolidge's yeah that's a good move
that's a good move it's good enough
all right guys chuckling that's cool
it's cool it's cool just Chuck's a
couple checks
oh I get to check packet I'll take it
I'll take it I'll take it
don't try to get funny boy I'll try to
get the phony no mori oh yeah you might
have had a chance but it just didn't
strike when it could have so I take you
go there I go there and I'm fine right
please you guys all right I'm going for
it you look scared
oh man I guess I should have been scared
Oh your plants crumbled
oh yeah that's a crumbled ha just in the
nick of time
and I'm gonna need a lot of Queens okay
I'm going to need a lot of Queens
it was almost checkmate
I think that's gonna do it for seconds
that's how it does it that's how I do it
I think everybody knows that uh usually
mic comes on top because he is more
experienced in the I am he played a lot
more games there has been this one
particular game where I managed to draw
him and my beginning stages of my chest
career and it was only that that draw
and say that win it inspired me to study
a lot more and I'm trying to make more
time for chess because I felt like it
gave me more progress in life okay
now before more late than ever
just something there
Oh
Morrow yo what is that alright alright
alright guys I see I see I see I see I
see I see I don't know if something good
but it's the a lot of calculation a lot
of calculation Wow calculation
all right
we can like dark squares even more
rock roll all right doesn't plans might
have worked out for somehow some way
don't that like a checkmate it okay
that's that's first on the gender I
don't want you to get chicken to eat I
didn't even money let's do a little
retreat
okay I'm gonna pray that this works true
just pray
alright you know what I might I might
even let you have it if you really like
it
I gotta go okay hope this is good okay
yeah it's closed it's closed
that was a good move for you I'll admit
it I will admit it
I'll admit it I'll admit it
oh right in the nick of time
comer comes up with the winning idea
please all Saiyans at home
mmm
don't know as much
I think I'm gonna be let's make a quick
break this one help
I like we better be going fast can you
go fast
yeah
you want to go
ooh that's not good
like drop drop drop well you are so
lucky all right well we're just
replaying the game ready yeah just as
good as I once was
I'm not gonna go back over there
little forecasts show the move I really
don't want to play this how humiliating
alright thanks Lee all right here comes
the fork
check
it's not the best camera
all right let's take this
barrio you did not wanna play that he's
like no this is the Mari or it's
expecting a flight in the holder yeah
yeah finally
yeah 30
all right let's play
yeah you can have a point
stop
you know I can't get them up that way
and want the other one
all right technically first okay I'll
take you okay all right
during the appetizers love it that's why
we do it are you
oh it's protective Mario yes I know
that's today nothing nothing
gotta play on the three that's gonna be
simple
Oh
or go for it
I'd read whatever you want to do
now I see how I see Chuck
who's going there okay okay
it's your move that's your move all
right
please say this it's got the checkmate
all right please please please check
check
come on where's the mate oh I found it I
found it that's I am so good that
finally my father made one everybody
okay pretend that you're my best friends
and all that I have to do they all know
this is what I dream about
alright I'll take a phone notice that
and all the game like enough upon I
crushed you the one game where I didn't
get up a pawn your practice across from
me just keep that all right lots of lots
of guys are taking that pull all my
people you gotta take my pawn
do take your time
I know it's been a theme of a match
pop discovered a mystic
difficult
and as well go for it
hold for bobby fisher' trick all right
so if you want to sort an attacking me
I'm gonna start attacking okay that's no
an h-file i come in as you recommend
recommend you
win this game it'll all be over
chief I've threatened g4 okay
okay
I'll take
taken
they're right around all right
all right
who kind of unscary but
protects the Queen and fortunately
yeah well no just okay just yeah okay
sorry all right
we're stuff laying already okay here we
go oh so bragging about my mating net I
got all my pieces but all my pieces go
good ideal I like your stuff okay okay
thank thank you so another successful
blitz bounty I guess I got just think
there's good sportsmanship at the end of
the day I think that every time I do
play my comer I get some some experience
and some materia to go over and learn
from